yes right Kim's is good stuff do you
like hymns
Kyle hymns yeah it's great we just did
an ad for it yeah I love him you do is
that what this songs yeah yeah yeah the
hy hymns is one of the products I oh you
do yeah your ear hair are you are you is
your hair receding yeah I I cut it a
couple of days ago I cut my own hair
ya know Wow but it's not it's fine it's
fine no it looks great
yeah I've been avenged old are you now
47 what's the same are we yeah 71 you're
going yeah it's in quite a bit we should
be closer you know I don't know I feel
nothing really I am too yeah always a
great time great vibes same age but we
don't hang out we don't hang out and
also on top of it is is that I when I
was looking for your number I couldn't
believe I didn't have it yeah yeah right
so I had to go through Instagram to get
it yeah yeah yeah I don't have mine as
well I'm a I do now but no I didn't you
didn't have it that's it that's well
that's weird
well plenty the scene when we just punt
to see it see if it grows I would I
would love that
let's see what happens right now I have
I think I have two friends I'd love a
third who's your friends my friend Kevin
is he a stand-up no uh-huh my friend
John is he stand up yeah John but he's
not in he's John Bush he lives in Iowa
wait you have a friend in Iowa yeah not
bragging it's a fact yeah yeah yeah
these are close friend yeah yeah do you
have a me it's hard is it was because
people just they take pride in having
150 acquaintances you know he's having
that like being in a social circle and I
think that it's humanly impossible to
make that many people happy or to be
genuine genuinely yourself around that
that's true yeah or to offer a real kind
of friendship to more than three people
absolutely yeah put the time because
everything else is just diluted after
that yeah it's a diluted friendship
nobody has that kind
energy me truly is the common I do have
a satellite friends I talk to not that
much
why is that would take home satellite
friends I think I think why Nappers
would this meet and say you and I let's
just be honest you and our satellite
friends I don't even what anybody I'm
not even a satellite I think we're even
salad friends oh yeah there's no right
so whatever no whoa so what would I be
then
future I mean you'll equates a guy love
everyone brings up um I love Bobby Lee
but it's an acquaintance it's more than
that it's less than satellite friends
that's great can we say a name for what
we'd have to make it up make it up all
the world kind of theory more than a
lesson a semi-pro would be a friend a
friend your old friend as well I get who
is that was my friend who you're a hoof
right when did you guys first meet I
have no idea
remember this must have been at the
store probably like 2000
yeah I mean I've known afore all very
long I remember our first interaction I
went what
and you went yeah in the darkness you
are yeah yeah like you're coming yeah
you're good
[Music]